blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
all right i haven't done like a
comprehensive
where we are in the pandemic type update
for some time
but it is time to do it a lot of things
have changed and there is much to
discuss
so to begin with we're starting to see
some
really significant improvements taking
place vaccines are being rolled out more
significantly
i know about the variants i know about
the so-called mutant
strains and i will talk about them i'm
not ignoring them i'm aware of them
i have the latest information as to how
they will affect
the vaccination program if this or if
that so i'm not ignoring that just give
me five minutes to get to it i know that
it's what
uh a lot of folks have been focused in
on but let's dive right in so first of
all
cases just the top line case number back
in december
i predicted cases would peak permanently
around january 10th to 15th now how did
i do this
am i an epidemiologist no am i a public
health expert no
was i special in predicting this no do i
want a pat on the back
yes but not for this um a combination
of experts were pointing out that
given the winter peak and vaccines being
rolled out
and the holiday effect we were likely to
see
a peak sometime around the middle of
january
and case in point case that's a pun
the peak for the seven day case average
came on january 11th when the united
states hit an
average of 255 000 cases per day
since then the number of cases has
dropped
by more than 40 percent to a seven-day
case average
of 147 000 cases so the bad news is
147 000 new cases a day is
insane it's tragic it's a disaster being
down
close to 50 in new cases per day
in just a three week period that is
absolutely fantastic and i expect that
by the end of the week we will be down
that full
50 now uh cases is one thing
but what about deaths uh we also had
reason to believe
that the death peak would come three
or four weeks after the case peak why
did we have reason to believe that well
we know from the last year of this
pandemic that deaths lag cases by three
to four weeks
and indeed the seven day rolling average
of deaths plateaued
over the last seven to ten days and
hopefully hopefully we'll be on its way
down
soon i had thought yesterday or today
would be the peak it turns out we've had
sort of a plateau
let's hope that those death numbers go
down from here
still and i want to be clear that even
as we see things improve
we don't want to forget that thousands
of people have been dying in the united
states
every day 4 000 down to 3 000 is still
insane it's still a 911 every single day
and there is a very long way to go but
the good news
is that the numbers are doing what we
thought they would in early december
based on a lot of different factors
including vaccination
let's now talk about that officially the
u.s has seen
about 27 million coronavirus cases
and the u.s has now administered not
distributed
administered 33 million vaccine doses
into the arms of folks so we now have
officially more doses than
number of cases that's a nice milestone
now if you remember my interview with dr
eric topple a couple of weeks ago our
best guess right now
is that the real number of cases when
you consider that many people never get
tested because they're asymptomatic or
they have mild symptoms and just never
go and get a test the real number of
cases is believed to be somewhere
between two and three times the official
number
but still it's a nice thing to be able
to say we've now given doses
we've given significantly more doses
than the number of total cases
as of right now as of this morning eight
percent of the u.s population has
received at least one dose
and about two percent of the us
population has received
both doses remember with the pfizer
vaccine
you have 21 days between dose one and
two
with the moderna vaccine you have 28
days between dose 1 and 2
you are not considered to be at maximum
immunity potential and remember
not everybody develops immunity but
close to 95
do you're not considered to have
completed the full course
of vaccination and antibody generation
until 7 to 14 days after your second
dose
what we know is that these vaccines are
working
really well infections and
hospitalizations
are down among those first vaccinated
this includes
health care workers and nursing home
residents
the two vaccines in play are pfizer and
moderna
and although the rollout was a little
bit slower than we would have hoped they
are accelerating dramatically
pfizer going to bring in additional
manufacturers a lot is happening there
we also have a third vaccine and more
but most imminently we have the johnson
and johnson vaccine
imminently to be submitted for approval
and within a couple of weeks after that
hopefully emergency use authorization
that's a one-shot
vaccine now let's talk about the mutants
the variants we have the uk variant the
brazilian variant and the south african
variant the concern being vaccines
are or might be less effective
against those variants some people
already going as far as to say they
won't work
the vaccination program is in vain we're
vaccinating against the strain
that is not even the strain okay let's
stop
let's sort of break it down a little bit
into its component parts because much of
what
we are being told so far is not true
first of all
the rate at which these uh i don't want
to call them primary yeah i guess we
could call them primary
variants or or significant variants are
mutating is exactly as expected for this
type of virus nothing is happening that
was not predictable in terms of these
types of viruses and mutation that's
number one
number two uh the as close as we can
currently get
to a reality assessment of the
effectiveness of vaccines on the
variants
is as follows the two vaccines currently
in use
pfizer and moderna in the united states
appear to be essentially as effective
against the uk
variant and the brazilian variant as
they are
against the sort of uh main strain as we
might know it
it is true that the antibodies
generated by these vaccines appear to be
less effective against the south african
variant
that doesn't mean that they don't still
generate enough antibodies
to be immune to for most people against
the south african variant and what i
mean by that is as follows
when you vaccinate people they generate
antibodies on a curve
and you know we we talk about it's 95
percent
effective what we mean by that is five
percent of people who get the vaccine
don't generate enough antibodies for
immunity now you might still generate
enough
to avoid a hospitalization or a death
but five percent don't generate enough
antibodies for immunity to the primary
strain
but you have a curve so you might have
just assigned fake numbers to it 95
of people generate at least a 100 level
of antibodies
90 generate at least 200
level of antibodies 80 percent are at
the thousand level
so on and so forth while it appears to
be true
that the antibodies generated are less
effective against the south african
variant
it may still be effective enough for
most people to be immune
imagine that the antibodies generated
are a thousand level and only
a hundred of them are effective against
the south african variant well
if the threshold to be immune is only 95
then you're still okay and i hope i'm
being clear about that
so we still are gathering information
about this
the idea that the vaccines don't work
against the variants
so far is not based in fact or science
it's not yet been demonstrated and
importantly this is a race against the
variants the variants are a reason to
vaccinate as quickly as possible
not to delay vaccination viruses mutate
by spreading
the more people that vaccinate more
quickly we slow the spread of the
variance
and prevent more people from getting
that variant which
may be less controlled by the vaccines
we currently have
moderna and pfizer both working on a
sort of modified uh booster in case it
is necessary for some period
down the road could be eight or twelve
months from now or maybe even longer now
as i said on the bonus show i was on a
wait list for leftover doses a lot of of
hospitals and vaccination facilities are
having issues where
because there's multiple doses in a vial
you might get to the end of the day
and have leftover doses and most
hospitals uh have some kind of on-call
list i have a friend who works at a
hospital i said put me on the list i
will
give me 30 minutes notice and i will
show up uh we don't you know
she doesn't want any doses going to
waste and neither do i
um i was able over the weekend to get
the first dose
of the moderna vaccine i had more arm
pain
being a lefty i got it in my right arm
more arm pain
than for any vaccine i've had in my life
i had a fever and flu-like symptoms for
about 24-30 hours
i spent saturday in bed i am now
feeling fine and i'm ready and waiting
for my second dose
in a few weeks now one last thing i want
to talk about
there are more and more articles being
written
expressing concern that these vaccines
are being undersold
and they're being undersold when you
hear cautious public health
experts say things like even after
vaccinated
you still should social distance and
wear masks and avoid indoor crowds and
all of this different stuff
and i think it's important to understand
that until we reach
a level approaching herd immunity we all
still need to continue taking a number
of the precautions that
many of us have been taking but we don't
want to undersell the importance of the
vaccine
because then you're going to see a lot
of people say what they are saying now
which is
even if i get the vaccine nothing
changes well then i'm just not going to
get the vaccine
the truth is that these vaccines
particularly pfizer and moderna are
almost
100 percent effective at preventing
death or even serious covid
that is a huge game changer while it has
not yet been confirmed
that the the vaccinated individuals
spread the disease to a significantly
lesser degree
that's what would be expected and that's
usually how vaccines work so i am a
little worried about the degree to which
the vaccines are undersold
as i said on the bonus show and as i've
spoken about with you know public health
officials and
epidemiologists who are speaking not for
the media but just kind of between
people
um in six weeks in eight weeks
a group of four or six vaccinated people
who work from home
are able to be together with extremely
low risk it is not zero nothing is ever
zero
but these vaccines are game changers and
we want to make sure we are not
underselling them and we continue
vaccinating as quickly as possible i get
people are being cautious
but if you we start telling people even
with vaccination you still have to
social distance and wear masks
indefinitely
a lot of people will say well i'm going
to opt out and we don't want that
send me your thoughts i am on twitter at
dpakman
this is good news notice i didn't
mention trump or biden in this entire
segment this is an analysis of the data
and the science of what is going on this
is not a political statement a political
segment of any kind let me know your
thoughts i'm on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is funded mostly
by viewers and listeners like you
through the membership program grab a
membership at joinpakman.com coupon code
available
never mandatory better21 all one word
better21
saves you just a massive amount on a
membership of your choice
at joinpakman.com so there's now a
discussion happening
about how soon joe biden and democrats
should wait
for republicans to negotiate on the
coveted relief bill
before just going forward and passing it
without republican support via budget
reconciliation
if democrats have the votes in the
senate now there are people
criticizing joe biden why is joe biden
meeting with republicans about the
coveted bill why is joe biden inviting
10 democrat
10 republican senators to meet as he did
last night
when these people are clearly bad faith
actors there's not going to be unity
there's not going to be negotiation that
gets us anything close to what joe biden
wants which is a 1.9 trillion dollar
package
and i basically agree with all of that
other than to say
the meeting is fine let's just
understand that after the meeting
republicans as we've already seen them
do this morning
are going to insist that they want some
pathetic 600 billion dollar
stimulus bill these same senators who
now are going back
to the tired old tropes of republicans
we can't afford it
but where's the money going to come from
but inflation
but the debt but the deficit people who
said nothing as trump
exploded the deficit despite claiming he
would pay off the entire national debt
during his first term these same
republican senators
gleefully happily voted for 740 billion
dollars for the military budget
just recently so they are hypocrites
they are exactly uh who we believe them
to be
they are going to obstruct and get in
the way and blah blah blah blah blah joe
biden's proposal is for 1.9 trillion
dollars
these republicans want 618 billion
and they met yesterday uh with joe biden
so
i think that the meeting with them is
fine as long as joe biden and democrats
are ready to say
listen remember they promised two
thousand dollar checks would go out
right away it's february now right away
we could debate
what right away means in government
speak but joe biden definitely made us
think jon ossoff definitely made us
think
that the checks were going out quickly
it's been a couple weeks almost now okay
so
it's time to do it have the meeting with
the republicans but understand that
republicans are going to make all sorts
of demands
they are going to demand capitulation to
their ideology to their platform
they will weaken the bill they will
weaken the impact of the bill
and ultimately even if you come up with
something that's between
600 billion and 1.9 trillion they'll
probably
still refuse to vote for it anyway okay
these are not good faith actors so don't
be
mad that joe biden is meeting with
republicans i'm fine with it
it's fine that he's doing it he claimed
he wants bipartisanship and unity and
all this stuff
that's fine they were able to propose
their 600 billion dollar package
and they are likely to vote against
whatever compromise democrats end up
proposing so
my view is give them the meeting and
then pass 1.9 trillion without a single
republican if that's what they want to
do now you need
joe if you don't get a single republican
you need joe manchin's vote and we need
to be sure
that joe manchin is going to vote for it
republicans will shriek
they will demand that they be met
halfway they will say what about unity
what about bipartisanship blah blah blah
but when it's democrats asking
republicans
to meet them halfway when trump is in
power
remember what republicans said well
elections have consequences
we're not going to just because you guys
want this different thing
trump won and we control this and we
control that so
democrats should have a spine and be
ready because
for an issue to have a compromise both
sides have to concede
things to make that work the republican
party is not offering to concede
anything
the democratic proposal is 1.9 trillion
and it's popular with the american
people
republicans are just saying no is the
concession that they will grant
any money because remember many
republican voters want the stimulus
package as well
this is not a stimulus package that is
only popular with democratic voters
republicans are not conceding anything
they are negotiating when they don't
actually have leverage
if joe biden and democrats are actually
ready and willing to pass this
without a single republican vote so my
suggestion is
ignore the bad faith whining of
republicans
democrats are passing popular bills that
60
70 80 percent of americans support
uh the executive order on masking from
joe biden
and you can't you know we talk about we
don't want to
stoop to their level we don't want to do
what they do listen we're not
obstructing anything
joe biden won democrats controlled the
house democrats took the senate
uh voters including independents
democrats but also republicans want the
stimulus
so just pass it you gave them their
meeting it's time to pass it you
promised you would do it
and i hope that they actually do this
could be the first major success of the
biden administration
and it will show that it's joe biden who
will set the agenda
and democrats not mitch mcconnell or
this will be the first major failure for
joe biden and it will be a big failure
when you say if i win and assaf and
warnock win
2 000 checks are going out right away
and we get
into february 10th mid-february late
february and you still don't have
anything past or you end up passing
something that's pathetic and paltry
that's not going to look good so it's
time to get it together
let's uh as we like to say put on our
big boy pants and get this thing done
these people these republicans are not
your friends they're not going to help
you they're not looking to compromise
they're looking to get in your way
you've got to go around them on this
important issue hey this is
super interesting cnn did an analysis of
the trump rioters who have been arrested
and found that many of these trump
rioters who were rioting because they
believe
the will of the people was not done and
that somehow joe biden is going to be
president even though donald trump
really won the election
a lot of those trump rioters didn't even
vote
this may not be surprised to many of you
cnn obtained voting records for more
than 80 of the initial arrestees
the majority did vote in the
presidential election um
but a bunch of them uh are not even
registered to vote
there are a whole bunch of people who
either aren't registered or did not vote
in the 2020 election and this is
interesting for for a number of
different reasons
first of all had they voted
they may not have felt the need to storm
the capital
because donald trump might actually have
won it'll if a lot of these
riotous insurrectionists had voted now i
know it's only a few thousand people who
went to dc
i'm including in that people just
generally supportive of the riotous
insurrection
uh what is very clear and and
unfortunately
unfortunate uh in terms of what it means
about american culture and society
is that conspiracy theories are far more
compelling than simply going out and
voting and participating in the
democratic system that we claim to have
they didn't vote but they're sure that
donald trump must have won
because hold on a second even they
couldn't be bothered to vote
and that is really something that should
cause some self-reflection if you are
saying
i am sure trump won because clearly more
people must have voted for him but wait
a second
i didn't even vote if i didn't vote
there's probably lots of people who
preferred trump who didn't vote
that moment of self-reflection seems to
never come
and before you know it they're in
washington dc breaking windows and
getting into the capital and messing
with
nancy pelosi's desk or whatever they
were doing imagine that
the concept of stop the steal of our
votes
when we didn't even vote stop stealing
our votes
i mean other people like i didn't vote
okay yeah but i'm talking about other
people
it's an incredible situation and uh many
may even have stayed home because donald
trump said it was rigged which again
raises the idea of whether trump himself
by saying
it's rigged don't vote early don't vote
by mail or do vote by mail
depending on the state but not
unsolicited ballots all of that stuff
may
also have held down turnout in a way
that was damaging to donald trump
now i have to be very real with you guys
with how close it was
it's probably a good thing that a lot of
these people didn't vote
trump really might have won if a lot of
these people
voted it may have been trump himself who
suppressed turnout
just enough to prevent him from even
winning and that's a really scary
thought
when you think about how close it was
and how it came down to
yeah i know that we talk about a massive
popular vote victory and the same
electoral margin for joe biden than
trump won with in 2016.
but it came down to you know 150 60 70
100 000 votes in a few states
much like the 2016 election now big
picture
it is not uncommon that people who
complain about government
doing or not doing something don't even
vote
that's not new that's not surprising in
the united states
often half the country doesn't vote much
more than half the country complains
but often half the country doesn't vote
in this particular election
it was about 35 40 of the country that
didn't vote it's an
ideology of memes conspiracy theories
and sharing fake news on facebook that
often doesn't actually include
voting they are more loyal to violence
and lies
than they are to the just basic
democratic systems that we have in the
united states
and that's a really difficult thing to
change when we talk about deprogramming
i'm going to have more to say about this
maybe tomorrow or thursday when we talk
about
deprogramming we have to understand that
this culture runs really deep
someone who is committed to
sharing fake news but can't be bothered
to vote
it goes beyond just convincing them that
their ideas are wrong it goes very very
much beyond that
let's take a quick break make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram david pakmansha
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today jonathan
franklin an investigative journalist who
writes for
the guardian is also author of the 2015
book 438 days an extraordinary
true story of survival at sea which i
recently read and recommended to the
audience
uh jonathan it's really great to have
you on yeah thank you so much you know
i'm glad you liked the fisherman boat
you know story this is a guy who's on a
boat all by himself for 14 months and
somehow survive
so you know for all of us who've been
through lockdown and confinement there's
a lot of interesting issues to help us
get through
yeah well maybe we'll start there so for
people who aren't familiar with the
story
of jose salvador alvarenga he
is originally a salvadoran fisherman
who while working as a fisherman in
mexico
in a storm ends up drifting off to sea
in a 25-foot boat
originally with his uh what would it be
called like first mate or just sort of
like an assistant i guess we would say
right
yes and ultimately because of the storm
did not make it back and actually
survived as the title of the book
suggests 438 days now
at the time was the previous longest
known
sort of precarious survival the 70-day
incident
no i think there was another one like
200 or something but this
of 438 days and we're talking on a tiny
boat i mean this is
not much longer than an suv
yeah and and so it's an incredible story
and obviously it exceeds the scope of
our conversation to tell it all
but needless to say it's an incredible
story that is
filled with both you know everything
from innovation in terms of how he
survived to complete and total
heartbreak and the reality of what
happens
uh after being essentially alone for the
large part of
of that 438 days when you take a story
like that and you want to tell the story
and it's someone else's story to tell
how much are you interviewing what's
your approach what do your notes look
like and how do you end up turning it
into the coherent narrative that it
became
well it's really interesting you asked
that david because this
was a victim of you know intense trauma
he goes off fishing for the weekend as
you say
he loses his motor he loses his buddy
who actually dies along the trip
he's almost starved to death he's in
huge seas
he has to catch fish with his hand he
has to eat raw birds
and somehow he kept it together and so
when i first heard about this i didn't
believe it i was like
he didn't he didn't look he didn't look
so skinny when he came off the boat some
things didn't add up
but on the other hand i figured if he
had faked it that was probably a pretty
amazing story
also so either way i had a story and
i flew to el salvador and i tried to
interview him and he couldn't talk
he was he was so in shock he i was it
was
one word answers almost like yes or no i
spent hours
just trying to you know loosen him up
and he was in shock
uh he would sweat he had nightmares so
it was
over the course of five or six months
where i ended up asking him
about 2500 questions which turned into
500 pages of conversations
and those 500 pages of conversations
which
was an exclusive deal that i made with
him
is the basis for the book in the book
you
describe many conversations and i'm
interested in in narrative non-fiction
there's a lot of different approaches to
uh dialogue and and sometimes like just
to pick
somebody ben mesrich will sometimes say
that that he's using sort of creatively
recreated dialogue that he feels
tells the gist of what took place but is
not necessarily literally accurate or
that stories may be combined or
separated or
whatever the case may be what was your
approach in
sort of describing and telling the
conversations that took place on the
boat between jose
and and his his crewmate well the
interesting thing here
is that the protagonist jose salvador
alvarenga about 33 years old
had never gone to school after about
second or third grade so he couldn't
read
he couldn't write but he fully
functioned in society
and one of the things i learned is that
when you're illiterate you also have the
ability
to develop an amazing memory because you
got to keep a lot of things in your head
if you can't read or write them down
that's interesting this guy had a
fantastic memory
and i could see it when i would
interview him about a certain scene when
he caught his first bird
and two months later i would interview
him again
and he just nailed it so he really had a
fantastic memory
and he uh you know the
dialogue is on in the book is not that
extensive i only use dialogue that i was
pretty sure
i could um you know get from his side of
the dialogue and then he would tell me
the other side of the dialogue
but the fascinating thing is he's often
doing a monologue because he's out in
the middle of the ocean
so the monologue you know he can tell me
what his monologue was
so we have these amazing scenes where
he's talking to a a whale shark for days
and days where
he talks to a whale shark he trains a
bird to be his pet and his pet becomes
i mean the bird becomes his pet and his
companion even when his buddy dies
he's he props up his buddy and he talks
to the corpse for a week because he
figures
talking to a corpse is a lot better than
being totally alone
right um you you mentioned that
it wasn't just you who was skeptical to
some degree
of the story initially and when you
consider that
the the we haven't mentioned this detail
but uh he actually washed ashore
with that same 25-foot boat uh in the
marshall islands
in the pacific in in the middle of
nowhere and one of the elements that
seems most compelling in
in the story is that of course there's
no doubt that it's the same boat he left
mexico with how how important is that
detail
in convincing you and others of the of
the story
well that detail like how did the boat
get there i mean you know you can't
fedex a boat
and the interesting thing is when the
guy lands
he has no interest in talking to the
press he refuses to talk to the press he
calls the press cockroaches and
he's trying to forget this trauma if
you're going to scam it it's probably
because you figure the publicity is
going to get you something so if you're
going to scam it
it's unlikely your first move is to tell
the press to blow off
uh there's that but on a science level i
don't know anything about ocean currents
especially when i started this so i went
to the scripps
institution of oceanography in the
university of hawaii and the us coast
guard
and all three volunteered very
generously to use
tracking software for ocean currents
drifting boats
and the university of hawaii had just
put a bunch of
gps drifters in off the coast of
mexico's you know
months earlier and it lines up perfectly
in terms of
if you're going to throw something like
a boat off the shore of mexico it's
going to end up in the marshall island
so that part also checks out from all
three of those
you know the coast guard scripts and uh
university of hawaii
so this this is a fascinating story i i
recommend it again to the audience the
book is 438 days now
to talk about some of the other things
you've done i i want to talk about um
the venezuelan uh assassin
sort of rehab camp in a moment but
before we do that
in the 90s i believe it was when you
were
of reporting for playboy magazine you
interviewed
timothy mcveigh is that that's right
that is right i'm one of the few people
who had an hour face time face to face
with tim mcveigh
in el reno prison so timothy mcveigh of
course
uh the perpetrator of the 1993
world trade center bombing what what are
the circumstances of
of that interview well the circumstances
are is that
i i was always curious about mcveigh
because you know a horrendous act i mean
what causes you to put a bomb in a
civilian building
and when i look back on it i found that
mcvay had been in the big red one
infantryman uh very very well-decorated
u.s
uh army soldier and when i started to
look at what he did
in the uh first gulf war in 1991
he was involved in a pretty horrendous
massacre uh
where a bunch of m1 tanks had bulldozers
put on the front of them and instead of
going
trench you know mano amano in the trench
warfare they just buried the iraqis
alive about 2 000 were buried alive
and reporters at newsweek won a pulitzer
prize for the cover-up of this story
huge you know big deal 2000 people
buried alive you know that
breaks a few contexts of most codes of
war yeah
mcveigh's job was to shoot off the
survivors with machine guns
so you can kind of see that without
justifying blowing up oklahoma which i'm
not doing and i don't want people to
take it that way
you have to understand the first time
this guy was involved in a huge
horrendous massacre he got medals for it
he was applauded you know he he
he had killed before it's very
interesting and very important i think
to look at the first time he killed
so when i went to the prison that's what
i talked to him about was
uh his war experience because i had
interviewed everybody
in his tank before uh i interviewed
mcvay
so when i go to interview him my first
question is tim
what was the name of your pet kangaroo
rat when you were in the gulf war
and he's like how do you know i had a
pet kangaroo rat and i was like jose
told me
how you know jose jose was the driver i
went out i was out snowboarding with
jose
ah you were hanging out with jose yeah
and so all of a sudden all those
barriers broke down and he's just giving
me the inside story of
what he did in iraq and how for him
oklahoma city was an echo of uh violence
perpetuated by the u.s government
against uh
all these people were buried alive in
the trench so there was for me
i thought it was very important to
figure out you know where does somebody
go
that kind of hyper violent yeah one one
of the commonalities that
i've heard from folks who have
interviewed those
uh who are known for or or have
committed
just disgustingly uh extreme acts of
violence
is that when they sit down with them in
a room there's two things that are
common one
how sort of unremarkable they are
sometimes physically some i mean i think
i think with totally true totally true
in this case
yeah i mean i think like with charles
manson that's a big thing where he's
just you know this little just kind of
this small
unremarkable guy but also and this is a
weird term to use
how normal sometimes these folks can
seem and there's a lot of kind of
connotations to that term but but what
was your sort of like general impression
of the man exactly
i totally agree with you because people
you know people want to see a monster
and probably i wanted to see a monster
and i couldn't help think like this is
the guy who like the neighbor who
shovels your driveway in the snow you
know he's a guy
he's from buffalo new york so he knows
about shoveling snow right
um and uh or it's the kind of guy you
could talk at a bar
um he was he was clearly intelligent
you know sophisticated vocabulary pretty
damn good writer
um you know you can call him misguided
insane whatever but
the guy had done a fair amount of
reading and you know he had he had his
own political philosophy whether you
believe it or
follow it isn't the point really but you
know this was not some some jackass this
was a guy
who for his own his own twisted reasons
or in his mind his own logical reasons
uh felt he had to attack the us
government and so i really like i said i
i was very interested in finding out
about his first kill
when um when when i've talked to former
uh kkk types white nationalists etc one
of the things that's frequently
mentioned
is that the way they got pulled into
their ex their extreme ideology in the
first place
came typically from a sort of
opportunistic situation typically they
describe
lacking a feeling of purpose or empathy
given towards them
as children or as teenagers at some
point in their lives
and the people that brought this uh
extreme ideology to them
bro the ideology really could have been
anything but it was the fact that
someone was paying attention to them
there was something approximating hey
somebody seems to care about me
no i call it tribal you know a tribe has
adopted me
i i saw this i went to las vegas and
spent a bunch of time with the young
teenage nazis of las vegas and
why were they nazis not because they
were anti-semitic or because they knew
much about hitler
it's because their parents were working
24 7 and they're 17 year olds and the
people who scooped him up were a bunch
of nutcase you know white supremacists
right the ideology could have been
anything that they were sucked into
muslim it could have been greenpeace i
mean
they you know they needed they needed to
pre you know a tribe they could have
easily been protesting against
tar sands and doing something you know
my views positive for the world they
could have been you know
they could have been building houses for
the poor they needed to be part of a
tribe
they found a pretty terrible tribe but
you can't deny that most 17 year olds
need a tribe and their parents are not
usually included
so how does that compare thinking now of
when you spent this time
with the four former uh
hitmen in venezuela how how does it
compare
with how they were originally pulled
into being hit men
exactly i think i think these guys could
have been hypnotic urban soccer stars
you know
what happened is i have some friends in
venezuela and
they told me they were running a rehab
camp for hitman i was like what
and so i flew out there and drove out
there and went out to the
back waters of venezuela and
sure enough there was a hitman rehab
camp and they said i could go camping
with the newest group
who were seven or nine different heads
of different uh gangs
and they were guys who hated each other
who would have likely killed each other
who had sent their assassins to kill
each other each other's troops
so they were stripped of their weapons
and they were just given like
flour and corn and matches and
and they were stuck on the top of a hill
surrounded by armed guards and they had
to just hang out for two or three days
cooking eating and um you know talking
around the campfire
but so who who organizes that i mean in
other words how how does one get into a
position to be one of the hitmen that's
part of that is it is it under duress
that they're doing this or oh they get
nope they get they get recruited by a
local businessman who had been
uh a victim of armed robbery and when he
started to poke into the armed robbery
suspects
he realized they were uh hitmen and
he offered them uh instead of turning
them into the cops he offered to let
them uh
work on his on his his rump in his rum
factory he's a big rum factory
so he tried to get them rehabbed them on
his own and then they started they
showed up with the whole
the whole gang it's like you know you
take in a stray dog and then the whole
pack comes in he took in two of these
guys and
the next monday they were all piling
saying we want to be rehab so
he hired a psychologist he hired some
former cops
and then they go head hunting they
single out the most dangerous gang
leaders in the hills outside caracas
and they and they convince them which is
not an easy process
to come uh try and go straight and
i was there living with them for about
maybe two or three
days on this mountaintop with all these
killers and i just had a little video
camera and i was just videotaping them
getting them to confess their sins
and so what what stands out to you about
those conversations and those
interactions
pretty remarkable that you can have a
group of 21 year olds who like give
zero value to human life i don't know
who to blame but they just
you know they would kill a taxi driver
because they didn't want to pay five
bucks
you know they uh they one guy killed the
classmate because he made fun of him in
seventh grade you know about his
homework
and these guys were hardcore um and they
assumed they were gonna die
if you if you lived to be 29 they called
your grandfather
you become a grant you know that was
like like a noble title
no nobody was expected to make it to 30.
so when you have that kind of
hopelessness
apparently it's still kind of shocking
you know killing somebody for money or
for fun or for
because you're in a bad mood is
extremely common in a place like
venezuela where
if you give me a thousand dollars i
could probably get a rocket launcher i
mean it's just there's a huge black
market of guns in venezuela so
uh you know you're a lot of desperate
hopeless violent men with
access to heavy-duty weaponry you know
just recipe for problems
you know one one of the things that some
will assert is that to some degree given
the right
economic circumstances and political
circumstances
that anybody placed into the situation
you just described could end up as one
of these 21 year old hitmen
how do you react to such a claim i mean
could could it really be anybody
no i totally don't buy it i don't i
don't believe i don't believe that
you know if you look at that famous
study where people were supposedly
torturing with electoral shocks and that
the study doesn't hold up that
if you look at that that didn't happen
most people refuse to
to torture you know lord of the flies is
fiction you know
so i definitely strongly disagree that
most of us have a potential hitman
inside us
what was the one i'm i'm speculating but
is there some risk to leaving that
lifestyle in venezuela and the people
were
were the people that were at this camp
were they taking a risk by saying
i'm going to quit this yes and no they
were taking a risk but staying in as
hitman is even
more risky i mean you've got to you know
being a hitman is like
you know it's probably your your career
is like like it's like the nfl it's like
3.7 years and then it's over
and is part of that because there's a
risk of getting caught and prosecuted or
is most of the risk not from the legal
system
no these were a group of 30 men and you
know they were down to like six of their
six of them were still alive you know
all almost all
you know so you know the average age of
these guys getting killed in
uh combat you know street urban combat
was about 18 or 19 and they were all
most of they were showing me their
bullet holes they all knew how to treat
bullet wounds which was pretty
remarkable you know
for 17 year olds to know how to treat
bullet wounds they used to piss on their
bullets before they go to combat because
they were sure
i don't think it's true but that that if
there was urine on the bullet that it
would cause a deeper infection on the
cops
wow you know these guys these guys were
out there um
and in fact a few days after my
interview the leader of the group was
caught by another group
and uh and chopped into pieces you know
more than murdered himself
this was a hyper violent crazy world and
i was trying to
just live with them and trying to get
them to go on camera and
tell me how i ended up this and there
are no easy answers you know i wish i
could say you know
keep your kids away from fortnite and
they won't be hit man but i don't think
it's that simple
no no it seems it seems not to be um
what are you what are you working on
right now
uh right now i'm doing a book on uh true
story of a cruise ship
that gets hit by kovid it's a look at
how the passengers and the crew come
together this is kind of the last cruise
ship to go out before the world blocks
down
and uh the crew the you know the people
start to die they get sick and so it's a
story it's kind of a
it's a thriller but it's also a
beautiful story of how you know too
a community at sea 2 000 people had to
find like a way to survive
because they were just they were adrift
for weeks no country would take them
how many people how many interviews do
you do for a book like that
150 180 wow wow and
is it even possible to keep the the sort
of
intertwined nature of the 150 stories
straight in your head or do you really
need to rely on
on notes and documentation yeah no way i
could do it in my head
no i got set i got seven dollars most of
my brains otherwise occupied
hey i'm curious you know the the the
narrative fiction
uh a narrative nonfiction genre um
is is very interesting to me and i've
i've read
you know diverse uh narrative nonfiction
including your work
and i mentioned in my email to you ted
conover who i interviewed has done
interesting work
john krakauer known for into thin air
and into the wild
what what are some of sort when you
think of the genre
what books and authors do you think of
i think of papillon you know the french
prisoner which may or may not be uh
narrative non-fiction because the
publisher on his deathbed admitted there
was a lot of uh
well went well beyond ben minrich's idea
of creating dialogue that sounds good
yeah so but but papillon fantastic
fantastic book there
into thin air still a classic um
you know perfect perfect storm the book
perfect storm is brilliant i mean
the movie the movie is well done but the
book is brilliant um
and um i guess those and i have to i
have to say what's interesting about the
one i did for
438 days is they did an audio version of
it
and i've never really paid much
attention to audiobooks but this one has
gone crazy and i think for any
of your listeners who who like
audiobooks or need an inspiring story
it's about seven or eight hours but the
the the reader
george i don't know but he did a great
job so we have a great you know really
good
reader and a thrilling tale so people
know people who are depressed
or even suicidal or you know just going
stir crazy like most of us
uh the audio version of 438 days
half the time you can get it free on
amazon get free if you can
but uh i think it's a it's a really
no because the book's a tool obviously i
make money on books but the whole point
of this book
uh was to hopefully stop people from you
know from suicide like
the goal of the book was if one person
reads his book and doesn't commit
suicide
you know that that was the goal the
fishermen and i set up from the
beginning because
the fishermen said look i've been
through mental stress physical stress
you know if i don't kill myself if i can
make it you can so i think there's a
really there's a really strong
um you know resilience and survival here
that goes
you know it touches a lot of people and
unfortunately a lot of people need that
message right now
well well well said uh we've been
speaking with jonathan franklin
investigative journalist writes for the
guardian author of 438 days
uh jonathan i so appreciate your time
today excellent well thank you very much
and i appreciate you know your questions
and a
beautiful interview well done the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this is super funny i told you guys on
yesterday's show that donald trump's
impeachment lawyers just quit on him
and donald trump yesterday was able to
get new impeachment lawyers at least one
a guy named david shone and he went on
fox news last night with sean hannity
and he just imploded showing us
instantly
what this impeachment trial is going to
be like here is donald trump's new
impeachment lawyer again
a bunch of his lawyers quit he got a new
guy telling sean hannity
that he might call democratic senators
or as he calls them democrat senators as
witnesses over what he calls
bias what yeah i don't know either let's
take a look
march to the capitol so your voices can
get heard and they take you right yeah
glad
yeah there are two points about this i
would say you also should be able to
call then
uh many of the senators as witnesses
because of the
awful bias and prejudgment they've shown
can you imagine any american citizen
considering it to be a trial in which
the judge and jury has already announced
publicly
that the defendant must be convicted
in this case and in fact senator leahy
called
demanded that senator mcconnell vote for
conviction also
um you know both sides everyone it's
clear to them donald trump undercut
undercut democracy how can we possibly
have a fair trial
chuck schumer senator schumer promised a
fair and full trial
you can't when you know that the juror
and the judge are biased going in
notice at the start that sean hannity is
actually defending trump's role in
inciting the insurrection
saying listen he was telling people to
go to the capitol to have their voices
heard
and it's funny to say democratic
senators
are doing something wrong by calling for
conviction
before the trial remember trump's first
impeachment
when republican senators pre-judged an
acquittal of donald trump where was this
guy then
where was sean hannity then saying you
know the trial hasn't happened yet so
they really shouldn't be prejudging it
they're not going to be calling any
democratic senators as witnesses anyway
by the way
then trump's impeachment lawyer says he
doesn't want any videos of the
insurrection shown at the trial
he says this has nothing to do with
donald trump in
the second thing is does this country
really need to see videotapes we know
now apparently
that mr swalwell and the other managers
tend to show videotapes of the riots and
people calling in
people being hurt police officers
talking why does the country need that
now
we would stipulate that there was a riot
that went on that day
it was a tragedy president trump has
condemned violence
at all times read the words of his
speech calls for peacefulness
this has nothing to do with president
trump and the country doesn't need to
just watch videos
of riots and unrest we need to heal now
we need to move forward
is that the speech trump gave when the
riot was already over
that david shone is referring to or then
the one that he gave
days later where he retroactively
condemned the violence that he was
gleefully loving based on reports from
the actual day of january 6th
it's funny how david shone keeps saying
the country doesn't need to see videos
of the trump riot
the trial is for senators now i
understand
it's nationally televised i know the
country will see
whatever evidence is put forward but the
trial
is for the senators to adjudicate what
justification is there
for not including relevant video
evidence
during the trial for the people who are
going to be adjudicating guilt or
innocence or guilt or lack of guilt
to make it easier for them to acquit
maybe
he doesn't want the videos put up there
oh
i don't know that that footage was never
presented and you'll remember that kelly
lefler
hilariously said at one point during her
senatorial campaign
when asked about the trump uh grab him
by the you know what tape oh i don't
what tape is that i don't know the
reason you put the footage in front of
the in front of the senators during the
trial
is so nobody can say listen i don't know
based on what i saw during the trial
which is all we're supposed to consider
i didn't see any reason to convict
donald trump now the republicans aren't
going to convict them anyway
but at least expose them for the shills
that they are by putting all of the
evidence in front of them including
video of the riot
now one last clip here's a possible
preview
of the defense strategy which is to call
the entire thing unconstitutional
and you've hit many of the main
arguments that i think are attractive
the american people
they're all right on but i'm going to
say to you that besides the fact that
this process is completely
unconstitutional
and that this is a very very dangerous
road to take with respect to the first
amendment putting it
risk any uh passionate political speaker
which is um really and against
everything we believe in in this country
foundation of the first amendment but
i'm going to tell you i think it's also
the most ill-advised
legislative action that i've seen in my
lifetime it is
tearing the country apart at a time when
we don't need anything like that
i think president biden missed a great
opportunity to be a statesman
and demanded that this thing be called
off frankly
this is the political weaponization of
the impeachment process
there was a rush to judgment uh listen
when president trump became president
the day he was elected
there were calls for his impeachment
ready this is the weapon they've tried
to use against him
um but now we know also that the agenda
um mrs pelosi and others is simply to
bar
president trump from ever running for
president again
and that's about as undemocratic as you
can get can you imagine the slap in the
face that is
to the 75 million or more voters
who voted for donald trump so this is
not
a first amendment issue donald trump as
president had the biggest bully pulpit
in the world
he used it and that bully pulpit caused
a riot
now there are possible consequences for
that speech
there won't be because trump will be
acquitted but these are the possible
consequences to your speech david shone
calling for joe biden to demand the
trial be called off by the way
is ridiculous as i've said for weeks and
months now
joe biden should have no involvement
whatsoever in the impeachment trial
trump was impeached by the house before
joe biden was even president
biden should do nothing one way or the
other period and then
david shone even sort of placates i
don't know if you noticed this
he placates the stop the steel
conspiracists he says
the 75 million or more voters who voted
for trump
that's a dog whistle that's the
suggestion that
okay 75 million people officially voted
for trump
but there may even be more uncounted
votes out there
that we still need to respect as well
this guy is absolutely
pathetic he's he's merely a political
hatchet man a political tool
he should be ashamed of of himself and
the trial starts one week from today
and we will be covering much of it we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 david p
here are some really basic questions
about q anon that i myself have been
asking
hey david i have a question regarding q
anon
i still don't fully understand i mean
from what we know it means one person
account or multiple people from one
account how is it
that this person hasn't been exposed yet
he says he's a government insider
yeah you believe that the fbi is
actually investigating who this person
is
how this say started you know
and where the responsibility lies as far
as
holding this person accountable for i
have no idea
these are the questions i've been at i i
i get the idea that
some people think q might be trump some
people believe
q is a group of people others believe q
is an individual
how does q communicate i guess
originally it was via 4chan but more
recently it's something else
it's as incoherent to me as it is to you
and to many of the people in our
audience
and i don't know if we'll ever get the
answers to the questions that are being
asked but they are good questions
we have a great bonus show for you today
anti-vaxxers briefly were able
to shut down dodger stadium's
vaccination site over the weekend
it's actually insane what's going on
with the anti-vaxx movement in the
united states
the number of hate groups declined in
2020
but the number of hate incidents went up
that's an interesting
a series of facts that we're going to
discuss
and we will also talk about this
situation between vice president kamala
harris
and democratic senator joe manchin who
is the most conservative democratic
senator in the u.s senate
what's going on with the two of them we
will discuss that and
much much more on today's bonus show
get instant access instant truly the
speed of light access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code better21 to
get yourself
a massive discount off of the cost of
the membership of your choice
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman